[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
Happy Taco Tuesday or is it berners
phone Tuesday I can't tell anymore
[Music]
never never know
what kind of news we're gonna wake up to
what is the slap in the face today as it
were it seems like um some people are
having trouble over on on the Tweety
tweets and the trendy Trends I'm having
a little uh trouble here on my phone as
well some people are saying in the
comments Twitter is not loading
get your [ __ ] together Twitter
we may have to all go over to Facebook
Nana that's not gonna happen either
it always happens right Facebook goes
down Instagram goes down everyone
migrates over to Twitter they're like
what the [ __ ]
is Facebook down
is Instagram down
and then you know whenever when when
Twitter goes down everyone migrates over
to Facebook
on you know un privatizes their account
Facebook
and then says his his Twitter down does
anyone know is Twitter down and so
Twitter may or may not be loading right
now I have no idea maybe I'm banned they
could have banned me that is possible
um but this is saying tweets are not
loading tweets are not loading some
people are saying there's a working
Debbie from Salt Lake was having trouble
good morning Debbie
uh Caitlyn says hey [ __ ] Em fam good
morning good morning Jay you're here
Kathy is here for us from Facebook
is here Jacqueline from Facebook
Victoria
Lillian Midas Robin Andrea good morning
good morning to all of you Nancy MJ is
here
MJ is here what's up [ __ ] fam she
says
good afternoon to everyone who doesn't
have a burner phone
[Laughter]
try to use to overthrow a government
like I don't know a democracy you know
the United States of America you know
[ __ ] and tear up our constitution I
don't know that might be a [ __ ]
problem
uh you can't make this [ __ ] up you
really can't
you really it's it's it's almost in
[ __ ] possible to make this [ __ ] up
anymore you could just we could just
start guessing all the criming these
[ __ ] did and nine times out of
ten we would be dead on
Mayo's here good morning Mayo
Christina's here
Kelly is here
from from Facebook but she says Twitter
is fine
[Laughter]
Twitter's not fine it's a sewer but I
love it I love the Tweety tweets and the
trendy trends that we're gonna go
through the Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trends today
we're gonna go through them of course
there's been a lot of news a lot of news
last week we had the wife of Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas
we had the news break
that she was uh uh between Jesus Christ
she was texting she was seditiously
sexting Mark Meadows the chief of staff
of the White House
Q Anon conspiracy theories gonna send
Biden down to gitmo and all kinds of
crazy ass [ __ ] releasing the Kraken
crazy ass queuing on [ __ ] she was she
was texting
the chief of staff to try to get the
president to commit a coup and then we
know that she helped fund all the buses
for the insurrectionist
that broke into the capital the
thousands of people that broke into the
capitol
laid Siege on our government
tried to overturn our Constitution and
our democracy we know she did that
they can't stop [ __ ] criming
and then once we get over the Will Smith
Chris Rock slap we find out
we find out you know the country's got
to do that 24-hour cycle you know when
something like that happens it's like a
half a billion views and everyone's got
to talk about it then we move the [ __ ]
on they apologize we move on
the [ __ ] out of the way we'll just make
comedic references to The Slap
that's what will happen
everyone's like oh it's too early no
it's not it wasn't too early five
minutes after the [ __ ] they gave
the guy an Oscar 20 minutes after he
slapped Chris Rock give me a [ __ ]
break too early my ass
[Laughter]
yesterday
we find out
well breaking
that a federal judge in California
releases an order
to release emails emails remember those
pesky [ __ ] oh my God emails probably
from a laptop
scary stuff emails from a laptop
their minds are gonna [ __ ] melt
John Eastman and Donald Trump were
exchanging emails on how to obstruct
Congress apparently and the judge out in
California says yeah there's a lot of
crime here
there there there's crime in here and
probably probably that crime should be
prosecuted
not just accusing John Eastman but also
accusing Donald Trump saying that there
is no attorney kind privilege when
you're criming you dumb [ __ ]
when you are trying to illegally
obstruct Congress from doing its Duty
that's your purpose is to criminally
obstruct them that's uh uh a felony yeah
those are felonies
so we had that news break
so not only do we have which
oh [ __ ] the story just goes on and on
and on
because even before the Ginny Thomas
story broke
that she was
seditiously sexting Mark Meadows to it
on conspiracy theories Mark Meadows is
committing voter fraud that's the
[ __ ] story we get there the chief of
staff who she was seditiously sexting
what am I wrong these are facts
he ran in a mobile home a trailer a
trailer house
in North Carolina so he could vote in
the state which he did not live
and then we get the story that Jenny
Thomas is seditiously sexting him and
now we find out that John Eastman and
Donald Trump
are criming through email
and then this morning
this morning we find out
that Donald Trump wasn't just flushing
documents down the toilet he may he may
have been flushing burner phones
burner phones are a possible thing he
was trying to flush down the goddamn
toilet at the White House I don't know
how am I supposed to know
I mean would you be [ __ ] surprised if
what I just said became a part of a
[ __ ] story that like yep six sources
say they watched him try to plunge
six burner phones down the commode
I would not be surprised
nothing surprises me anymore
I mean you can't eat how the [ __ ] are
they even gonna make the movie to be
more dramatic than what reality is
and how stupid and comedic it is
how in the [ __ ] did they think oh well
we'll just use burners and they'll never
know they'll never know we didn't use
our official phones think about that for
a second
think about it for one [ __ ] second
they log everything the president does
everything
because he's not just a dude or a gal
holding office that's our president of
the United States
our president that's the office not just
a [ __ ] person
they log everything they do everywhere
they go for official record
it's part of our documentation of that
office
it's part of the historical record
and normally we don't see some of this
historical record until decades later
because normally there isn't just
criming and criming and criming and
criming
in these White House logs
where they're logging what the president
is doing
foreign
but there's over seven hours seven
[ __ ] hours that they can't find a
phone calls
and we already know we already know of
two confirmed phone calls that that
[ __ ] made
Kevin McCarthy was on the phone during
The Siege on the capitol When Donald
Trump was trying to attempt the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup he went on the news
and he said he talked to the Cheeto dust
mobster
he said he talked to Grandpa Poopypants
he talked to him on the phone
from the capitol
during that time period
where there's no records
so which is it is Kevin McCarthy making
all that [ __ ] up
right there on the spot that day I'm not
talking about like he just he went back
and retold the story he was on the phone
with on national TV live
talking about how he just got off the
phone with the president United States
and that and that phone call that he
says he made
is not in the record
it's not in the record
so who did he what phone did he call
maybe this is why
they were all seditiously sexting Mark
Meadows
because the word was
that Grandpa poopy pants was gonna go
dark
on his phone
nah nah he's not gonna use his phone
that day while we're trying to attempt
to overthrow the government would be a
bad look if we had a log of how he was
trying to overthrow the the Constitution
of the United States that would be a
horrible [ __ ] look let me tell you
when the Military Tribunal is down to
get both start that's the [ __ ] they
think
he says where their minds go
look
some people say the cheese slid off the
cracker well the sprinkles have slid off
the donut folks
the sprinkles have slid off the [ __ ]
donut
and we know we know that there's reports
of burner phones
we've seen this in the months and months
prior
with Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump with
reports that they were trying to buy
burner phones and get AIDS to get burner
phones well now maybe we know who they
were for
hmm
and and then the fat [ __ ]
that [ __ ] slob says this says over
the weekend I guess or for the for for a
statement
he didn't know what the [ __ ] a burner
phone is he never heard of one never
heard of that term before in his life
I've never heard of a burner before
he thought he thought it was skid marks
in his undies
that his staff cleans out
maybe that's what he thought a burner
was I don't know
he eats a lot of [ __ ] fast food he's
probably got a lot of skid marks a lot
of burners in those undies
but he never heard that term before
burner phone I never heard that term
before
don't know what it is
yeah my [ __ ] ass just like Rudy
Giuliani is the coffee boy
and Sydney Powell
she didn't he didn't know who she is
either
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
Jenny Thomas was texting Mark Meadows
the chief of staff
to put Sydney Powell in charge to
release
the Kraken
they had burner phones
that they were [ __ ] plotting to
overturn our democracy
you can't you can't make this [ __ ] up
you really can't you really can't and
the thing that gets me here is again
how they didn't think that there was
going to be a gap in the log they how
they're like oh you know what we'll do
we'll just get burner phones that way no
one knows that we were on Burner phones
like well I mean if they're logging
every single [ __ ] call you're making
in the official record and then there's
no [ __ ] logs because there's because
you're making calls on a burner phone
that there's going to be a gap
like there's gonna be a gap
so was he on a burner phone or did they
destroy those records because he has a
history
of eating Big Macs with the side of top
secret documents
maybe he stole them I don't [ __ ] know
do you does anyone else know out there
exactly how the [ __ ] this works
no the reason why we don't is because
we've never had to know I mean we knew
back when Nixon right when they wanted
the tape
and they erased 18 minutes of the tape
18 minutes they erased
which is kind of funny if you think
about it right because Trump really
wants to beat Nixon you know maybe
consciously or subconsciously I don't
[ __ ] know he definitely wants to be
Nixon though he wants to go down in
history as the the most corrupt most
most criminal president that we've ever
had apparently probably look at it how
could you not look at the evidence and
think that
but think about this for a second Nixon
accomplished in 18 minutes
what it took Donald Trump over seven
hours to do and [ __ ] cuck
God damn
so ridiculous so [ __ ] ridiculous
that we have that we have to continue
to act like
that this guy
was an actual [ __ ] president of the
United States
we don't need to act like this anymore
this guy was a criminal
he was a criminal he was trying to
overthrow our constitution if you're if
you're a patriot out there and you're
and you got a trump sticker a trump
shirt a trump hat a trump flag you are a
[ __ ] traitor
got it
you're a [ __ ] traitor
a traitor to your fellow Americans a
traitor to your flag a traitor to your
country a traitor to the Constitution
you're a [ __ ] traitor
and you
should be treated as such
they should be ashamed
ashamed
to have anything with his [ __ ] name
on it anywhere
ever
be associated with him at all they
should be scrubbing their [ __ ] social
media accounts right now as we speak
with not just the [ __ ] news of the
burner phones today of the Gap in the
phone calls because we know all we know
what that is
we know we know we know that the Oath
Keepers and the proud boys who are
charged with seditious conspiracy one of
them has pled guilty in court who was
Roger Stone's protect who was Roger
Stone's personal protection that day
Joshua James of the oathkeepers
who is one of Stuart Rhodes lackeys
that Stuart Rhodes had the authority
over the qrf across the Potomac the
weapons
Enrique tario met Stewart Rhodes the
night the day before January 6 in a
parking garage even against the court
order that he could be in the city of
D.C
he has been indicted and arrested under
conspiracy to commit sedition
I wonder if Roger Stone had Donald
Trump's burner number that [ __ ] day
you goddamn right he did you God damn
right he did
who do you [ __ ] think was
communicating with who
we've had Dakota Adams and Tasha Adams
on this show who is Stewart Rhodes a
strange wife and a strange son and they
have told us
they have told us
that they know Stuart they know the ins
and outs of his mind
and they know how deep his delusion was
of what Donald Trump could deliver him
or protect him from
and the qrf was designed to wait for
chaos
and Chaos from the other side black
lives matter are antifa or whatever they
were looking for whatever chaos they
were looking for never came that day
it never came the only chaos was from
the insurrectionists the traitors the
seditionists
the Trump supporters
the Trump the Trump humping rednecks
that day at the Capitol
that's the only chaos that ensued there
was no uh other than the police officers
trying to beat back the insurrection
there was no pushback
there was no even from the National
Guard the president United States and
DOD called them off
because they knew that would stop the
insurrection
everyone was really [ __ ] pissed off
over the weekend when Will Smith smacked
the holy [ __ ] [ __ ] out of Chris Rock
really [ __ ] pissed off everyone got
pissed off for a lot of different
reasons a lot of different [ __ ]
reasons
they were pissed off at the joke they
were pissed off at the slap they were
pissed off at this pissed off at that
these [ __ ]
tried to take your [ __ ] life away
from you
your cozy little community
your cute little school
you're quaint little church your way of
life your job the economy
they wanted to take it all away from you
you voted you decided who the president
of the United States was and the State
Certified that [ __ ] vote
and they didn't give a [ __ ]
they didn't care
why would they
why they're fascist they get to tell you
what the [ __ ] to do
and that's what they wanted to do
they wanted a way to tell us what to do
with our vote and why we were wrong
foreign
Well turns out over and over and over
again as evidence
keeps coming out and we keep seeing the
story more clearly
that they wanted our democracy to fall
because democracy
democracy
is not the friend to Fascism it's
fascism's enemy
democracy tears down
fascism
we see it in Ukraine you see the people
in Ukraine right now
fighting valiantly against the Russians
beating them back
the word is today that Russians of
course the Russians are lying don't ever
believe any [ __ ] thing the Russians
say
it's kind of like Donald Trump like you
know there's Putin and there's [ __ ]
tubby Putin right there's Big Mac Putin
there's Putin you know the Russian gay
Vladimir and then there's Big Mac Putin
the Cheeto dust mobster Grandpa
Poopypants
you just take what they say and you just
automatically go it's probably the
opposite
and you're going to be right 99 of the
time when you do that like when you like
like when he said I don't know what a
burner phone is yeah that's the opposite
you're probably correct
it's it's really easy it's really easy
so don't don't take what the Russians
say
as truth
when they're saying they're regrouping
they're getting their [ __ ] asses
kicked
they're not regrouping
to negotiate they're regrouping because
they're getting [ __ ] they're getting
[ __ ] slapped worse than Will Smith
[ __ ] slack Chris Rock
that's what's happening
because democracy is resilient and the
reason why is because human beings
generally want their [ __ ] Freedom
who'da [ __ ] guessed it that human
beings want their [ __ ] freedom
they want their rights they want their
[ __ ] Liberty
foreign
why do you think people are [ __ ]
going whoa whoa whoa wait wait a second
Rhonda Sanders signed a bill that says
what
you can't say what what you can't say
gay
why can't you what they're scared of the
word gay
they're supposed to be the anti-cancel
culture
party and they're canceling the word gay
you don't think that they that don't say
gay bill in Florida you don't you think
it doesn't have anything to do with the
Insurrection you're wrong it has
everything to do with it
it's part of the soft coup folks it's
part of the slow walk to a fascist state
that they want
they're at the doorstep
they were pounding on the door on
January 6th
lucky for us
it was a [ __ ] buffoon in charge
a buffoon with a burner phone all right
let's go to the Tweety Tweets in the 20
trendy trends
the shitless Roundup let's round up this
[ __ ] list because there's a lot of [ __ ]
to round up today let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome to the shitlist Roundup where we
round up all the Tweety tweets and the
journey trends of the day
Hill just like every goddamn day we got
a huge a huge list to get through we got
burner phones we got Eastman emails we
got Mick Mulvaney has entered the chat
again everyone wants to boycott CBS News
and CBS because of this uh we have
Madison Gotham uh that's trending I have
no [ __ ] idea why cawthorne is
trending probably because he's a he's a
[ __ ] racist piece of [ __ ] that's
probably why even Walther Cronkite is
trending this morning God bless his
heart Walter would probably be
rolling over in his [ __ ] grave if he
seen what's happening
um the 25th Amendment kellyanne Trump
have you ever heard of kellyanne Trump
kellyanne trump is trending apparently
she's a new family member of the Trump
family I'm not sure what's going on
there but we'll we'll investigate
Merrick Garland of course is trending
because
uh last night we seen the the vote for
contempt
for uh Peter Navarro that piece of
garbage and and uh his his piece of
garbage and kind Dan scavino uh we're
gonna play the tape from Jamie Raskin
holy [ __ ] God damn that's what I said
God damn
that's what I said in my tweet God damn
he he really he rakes him
Jamie Raskin
does not [ __ ] around
he is not [ __ ] around anymore
he's gonna he's out to get these
[ __ ]
he's gonna get to the bottom of it now
also um that that that
um fascist and not a journalist fascist
they got the longest they always call
him a journalist he's not a journalist
he's a fascist Andy no
and Jordan Peterson in the news I don't
know if we'll get to that garbage or not
but we might get to
that fascist Andy no
so let's go to the two let's go to the
timeline first
let's go to the timeline here let's see
what let's see what's in the timeline
anything good in the timeline let's make
this a little bigger so you guys can so
you guys can see the Tweety tweets and
the training trends
now we have Gabe says burner phones
never heard of them Donald Trump
seriously like that's the quote
literally that is the [ __ ] quote
that's the quote
he didn't know what burner phones are
no idea
I said uh you know there's a big gap
there's a big gap in the phone records I
said big gap little weenie
I don't know I'm just I just [ __ ] and
throwing stuff out there maybe I should
stop tweeting I you know I I think maybe
I don't tweet enough and then I think I
tweet way too much with a tweet like
that I think I'd tweet way too much and
big gap little weenie
um
and
Joe says I gotta admit I didn't think
the flaccid former guy was capable of
maintaining
maintaining an Insurrection that lasted
longer than four hours let alone seven
and a half
an Insurrection and it really is it
really is surprising that he was able to
to sustain longer than I don't know 30
seconds uh the Mayo it says mail are you
still here male Mayo says democracy is
lost if Donald Trump isn't held
accountable
you goddamn right now this is this is
interesting this is an interesting tweet
here's why it's interesting
here's why this is interesting is
because Donald Trump is possibly going
to be held accountable in more ways than
one
I mean this this January 6th thing this
treason thing is really barreling down
on that's probably not going to be
treason or sedition they're probably
going to charge him in a federal court
with several several charges of
obstruction obstruction of Congress
being one we see that we see that from
the federal judge in California uh
giving the green light to Merrick
Garland to consider
in a federal capacity to indict a former
president of the United States of
obstruction of Congress like he he lays
that out right like that's that's a
thing
uh and and so we're you know so so we're
gonna see that probably
now thank you Ken for the Super Chat
Tony plus Gabe you guys are the best oh
thank you very much Gabe's Gabe's
supposed to be joining us here really
soon of course the bottom of the hour as
he as he always does he's always late
always with without the microphone but
we'll get him on we'll get him on and
we'll get him here
uh so thanks for the super Jenkins
but but setting setting the whole
treason Insurrection sedition thing
aside
uh we see we see a thing's heating up in
the Manhattan DA's office everyone
thinks oh well this is this is going the
wrong direction this is going the wrong
direction if you want Trump to be held
accountable no not really
pomerance releasing or whoever released
it I'm I'm guessing pomerant somehow got
the the his resignation letter pomerance
as you know from Michael popock from
legal AF being on the show last week you
would know that pomerance
pomerance is the uh Special Assistant to
the D.A
that was in the Manhattan DA's office to
prosecute Trump's case specifically
he resigned and everyone was wondering
why the [ __ ] is he resigning because uh
Alvin Bragg the new Manhattan da who
replaced cyvance
apparently was not Prosecuting which
then we seen the evidence of that with
pomerance's resignation letter basically
saying Trump did crime charge him with
it [ __ ] I mean that's you know that's
my phrasing my freezing but you know
paraphrasing Trump did crime prosecute
that [ __ ] basically
this is what pomeran said
so so we have that going on and the
reason why that's significant and
important you even heard popock say that
that's not over everyone thinking that
that that situation is over is not
exactly the governor of the state of uh
New York has the power to assign a
special prosecute or even replace the
the D.A Alvin Bragg which they've had
several meetings
and the reason why is because the the
crimes are against the state of New York
a lot of the crimes that they'd
committed are against the state of New
York not not just people but the state
for tax fraud right
so the crimes are against the state
which the governor is the executive of
the state so she has the right to seek
out anyone who's committed crimes
against them and she can have a special
prosecutor and sign a special prosecutor
to do that
which all that evidence that Paul
Marantz and their team and PSY Vance and
their team uh gathered up against Trump
and the Trump organization with the
current indictments even
of the CFO and the Trump organization
itself that's all there that ain't gonna
go away
now you also have the Civil the Civil
accountability that's going to be held
in the state of New York against the
Trump organization with Tish James the
Attorney General tis James as you know
if you if you look back and you do a
little bit of Googling you would know
that she actually cut down the Trump
Foundation their charitable Foundation
like a fresh cut tree
and I think that's her goal with the
Trump organization you know just Smash
Up the old money laundering machine that
is the Trump organization I think that's
her goal
so there's a lot of accountability
coming for Donald Trump and not just in
New York and in Washington we also see
cases down in Georgia possibly in
Arizona even
a voter intimidation
and voter fraud no
there's that much voter fraud there's so
much voter fraud out there
Genie Thomas we need to take him to
military tribunals for all the voter
fraud that we're committing not their
committing [ __ ] boneheads okay
oh here uh Rachel uh retweeted this uh
because I retweeted it as reported by
Robert Costa and real Bob Woodward eight
hour activity Gap quote unquote and
White House Records suggest Trump may
have been using burner phones
on January 6.
so here is uh CBS This Morning
everyone's wanting to boycott CBS look
look folks I'm gonna get to the mick
Mulvaney thing and I'm going to give you
my opinions on Mick Mulvaney and CBS
but you know let's let's actually let's
concentrate on [ __ ] that we can we can
accomplish like winning the 2022
midterms like if you put all your weight
and all your might behind the 2022
midterms like local elections not just
not just national elections
but like uh I don't know state
representatives Governors attorney
generals secretaries of State
put some of your [ __ ] boycott energy
behind those candidates don't worry
about CBS CBS ain't going anywhere
dumbass it's a network television their
Network television CBS ain't going
anywhere they're not going anywhere
they're not
and and and yes it's and we're gonna get
to the mick Mulvaney thing it is [ __ ]
despicable that they hired him but uh
let's listen let's listen to a little
bit of what Bob Costa has to say uh we
got Gabe coming in here soon but let's
listen to a little bit of what Bob has
to say and then we'll go and see what
gave things I've obtained 11 pages of
internal White House records from the
day of the attack that were turned over
to the January 6 committee they show for
the first time a detailed an official
account of Trump's phone calls and
behind the scenes activities that day
they also notably contain a gap in the
official records during the assault
something is missing since the Gap
stands in contrast to extensive public
reporting about his calls at the time
so Gabe how are you this morning do you
did you you know I I tried to get a hold
of you but I was I wasn't able to reach
you on your burner phone so yeah it's
I'm I'm working on a new plan okay okay
so right it's it's a it's you know I'm
switching between providers you know is
it like sedition Wireless is that is
that the one that you're going to or uh
yeah no well it's it's it's seditiously
wirelessly oh I see wirelessly yeah that
sounds more like what they yeah
it sounds more like what they would call
it so uh Bob Bob one of the Bobs here
there's Bob Costa and Bob Woodward yeah
Bob Woodward another another one of the
people that I really and it's like
thanks for reporting but thanks for
reporting now right right well you know
they they are they are um they are
putting the ball up on the tee with this
one oh yeah because they I don't know
you know here's the thing like is it I'm
just like are they reporting now because
they said to themselves hey we should do
the right thing right or are they
reporting out because like we got a lot
of [ __ ] also I just released the books
already made my money you know right
right I I already made the money off all
this Edition right maybe any any
sedition that way he's like I already
made my money on all the covet deaths
but now let's get over to sedition right
right right let's go to the trees and
that happened well
um let's watch a little more here at
this report because he does talk about
like uh Mark Meadows and or not excuse
me uh uh Kevin McCarthy as chaos engulf
the Capitol building on January 6th
president Trump spoke repeatedly on the
phone with allies and supporters some of
whom urged him to put an end to the
violence but none of those calls are
reflected in the 11 pages of those White
House Records for January 6th given and
what he's talking about here is the um
he's talking about the call that they
made the Mike Lee and then the call that
they made to Kevin McCarthy and we have
evidence of the Kevin McCarthy call
because Kevin McCarthy and I think it
was ABC who he was on the phone with do
you remember who Kevin McCarthy was on
the phone with can you maybe find that
yeah let me find that find that audio uh
or video of it
uh of that day because Kevin McCarthy
was on the phone live on air
um from the capitol talking about how he
had just got off the phone with the
president United States at the time
which is the Cheeto dust mobster Grandpa
Poopypants Donald Trump
um that he just got off the phone with
him the problem is is that babo here is
finding that there is no record of that
phone call in this log so either either
a that call never happened and Kevin
McCarthy's full of [ __ ] or which I I
know he's full of [ __ ] but I think in
that moment he wasn't lying like
yeah it almost it almost gives you a
sense of how much did everyone know
about the coup right right like how
involved was everyone
was everyone really abreasted exactly
what was going to happen or not
but he calls he calls Mike Lee
right and and Galen says here remember
the calling Mike Lee on accident
thinking it was Tommy tuberville and I
think that was Rudy Giuliani yeah
actually yeah yeah that was the uh that
was the voicemail that got left on his
phone so I think so I think the call
from Rudy Giuliani was the mistake and
then and then they ended up calling and
maybe it's because they were trying to
they were trying to look at numbers on
their phones and then trying to type the
numbers in on their burner phones yeah I
don't know you know I I've never I've
never really used a burn so yeah well
you hang out let me
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna reveal
things I've done in my past what I will
say
is uh the fact that
you know they're
they're that clumsy right like they're
if you're using a burner phone and
you're trying to cover up for this
active sedition that you're you know
right over to the government like
you would think that well then again
it's this group so I'm not surprised but
if you really were trying to do this
correctly like you would have protocols
in place
in terms of uh of who was communicating
and how to right like you mean like
burner phone protocol is that what
you're saying like right like is there
like an etiquette for burnouts they're
you know here's the thing like let's say
that you are
you know arrested right or you're taken
into custody right you've got one you
don't want to have everything on you
right you want to have one or nothing so
you would have
um layers of redundancy or layers of
precaution where you would have other
people in place like you would relate
like if we're all in the same room
together
I wouldn't be having multiple phones
trying to text people right like if I
especially of older people uh like Rudy
Giuliani you know that guy where his
hair is melting like I'm he can't he
can't keep track of anything he can
barely he can barely he can barely get
on the PornHub website right so you know
you know I look at this and I'm like
it's
it doesn't it doesn't surprise me that
they would do it this way like somebody
would literally I'm sure like there was
multiple people with multiple different
phones all doing the same thing at the
same time
instead what you would do is you would
have one person with one phone who was
communicating like on the public side
right and then you have another person
where you would relay and be like this
is what you got to say to this other
person on the burner side right you
wouldn't have one person with all
control because again you're gonna mix
up phones unless they're not let you
know a lot of times you're also properly
label the phone it's not like oh I meant
to text on this phone and then I
accidentally texted on this phone you
know and then you're sending you know so
you're saying like there's there's
there's uh there's a phone for each
person they were trying to contact like
let's say that let's do the smart way to
do it because let's just say yeah you
know there's a qrf across the Potomac we
know that right um and let's say you
wanted to have a phone that communicated
with that qrf maybe maybe just maybe
um you would you would uh use Roger
Stone who had protection from The Oath
Keepers who can relay the message
through other burners is that what you
is that kind of what you're saying like
you have a burner phone at the White
House labeled Roger Stone Roger Stone
possibly has a burner that's labeled
White House and then and then he relays
the message to Joshua James who's
standing next to him and I'm I'm just
I'm just here listen I understand is
that is that what you're saying
how to do crime here
this is how I'm gonna tell I'm gonna
tell everyone here how you do it um this
is what happens you would separate the
lines of communication because you never
want the same line communicating with
these like multiple groups right you
want to break it up and be like oh it
was only between the last four digits of
seven six seven nine and eight three
zero two those were only communicating
you don't want those numbers to to jump
off into other Communications because
what you would be able to do is you'd
say it was only an isolated uh Channel
it was only between this phone and this
phone as opposed to it was between this
phone and this phone and also this phone
and this phone and this phone and this
phone because then you could tie it all
back together because then you can tie
other people into the what do they call
that conspiracy right right exactly and
again the phones and the conspiracy
because we're talking about burner
phones here these things like don't have
you know there's no name activated to
them or anything right yeah you know
like it's like a calling card and other
people of the of the Trump family had
burner phones like uh Eric Trump Laura
Trump
um I'm blanking on her name uh she was
an aide that she came forward a few
months ago
um and revealed that she was supposed to
buy phones for
um uh blanking under name and her mother
as well
um uh and then of course you know I'm
sure Don Jr had a phone for like his
drug dealer or whatever but like that
wasn't involved in the gymnastics
Edition he was like he's like you guys
got burner fronts I got a profile too
you know and like right but but but
that's where they would learn that's
where they would learn this this uh this
way of you know what you're saying not
connecting dots right right like not
having people what if you were smart
about it you would uh
between one phone and only one other
phone well let's let's be frank here if
you were smart about it you just
wouldn't try to overthrow the government
well yeah yeah I mean like that's like
you would just you would just you would
just go I lost okay it's over we're not
gonna try to commit a coup it's probably
a good idea because we've talked to
Stuart Rhodes as a strange son Dakota
Adams right and he claims that the
reason why Stuart Rhodes was so obsessed
with January 6th and why he kind of did
a 180 on what he really felt like with
the Constitution is because he was
terrified of indictment and I actually
think that that mentality is not far off
from what um Donald Trump and the people
around Donald Trump were suffering from
this mentality that if we don't remain
in Bower
we may get the hammer and by doing that
they're committing more crimes and
they're only creating a bigger Hammer to
smash down on them right of course this
is down Donald Trump's whole life story
I mean yeah oh he's sorry and Amy Amy
kremmer the co-founder of women for
America
um she was the one is that one of the
ones that was in the garage wasn't it
women no no no okay no no that was the
Latinos for Trump oh okay that's right
yeah she's the one who
um was one of the people that were
helping to run the uh
the stop the steel rally that they had
the big lie oh yeah yeah that day but
it's like you know this is again this is
from November 2021 and it says you know
she played her key role in drawing the
president supporters of Washington here
and speak on the on at the White House
um allegedly use so-called burner funds
to communicate with the president's son
ahead of the rally that was according to
a rolling stone article
um and it was her Aid that came forward
but yeah it was like people who had
burner phones Eric Trump
Eric Trump's wife Lara Trump Mark
Meadows so it's like those you think
those text messages that are on the
burner phone you know probably not going
to be able to get a hold of those so the
ones that we've seen are the one because
like you have to also remember like who
has certain uh who who have been privy
to certain lines right and right you
wouldn't know the burner number right
unless right so that's why when the
phone calls or the text messages come in
from Sean Hannity or Laura Ingraham or
Don Jr those those are coming into his
personal so they haven't been privy so
that means what you're saying is that
means Don Jr didn't have a burner phone
line
well he didn't have a burner phone for
no no like that that's right that's what
I'm saying he was he he was so it yeah
his dad loves him so much that he didn't
even
they said they said you got he was like
I got a beautiful too and everyone's
like okay great great Don like yeah good
job good job buddy he was he was texting
someone I don't know his his dealer that
day was like God
will you leave me the [ __ ] alone he's
like yeah totally yeah that sounds that
sounds crazy you guys are doing what oh
that's awesome your dad doesn't love you
oh cool like I'm not your therapist I
wonder what it's like to be Don Junior's
drug dealer really I bet you
I forget you yeah I know I bet you his
drug dealer uh probably looks at the
interactions as like
well at least he pays me right well does
he though is he well I would I mean I
would hope so but yeah it's like well
I'm sure he's embezzling money from the
company and he's using it to pay funds
you know uh you know maybe he's not
paying alimony to his wife you know for
child support or whatever so it's like
I'm sure he's using funds that way uh
again I'm not commenting on people with
addiction I'm commenting on Don Jr the
[ __ ] douchebag okay why I mean I mean
don don Junior's got a lot more problems
than addiction let's let's oh yeah
totally I mean you look at this book do
you get that a lot you get that a lot
when you do a John Junior video they're
like you're making fun of people with an
addiction I've had people that have
commented about the addiction side and
I'm like I'm not like okay one it's a
character and I'm exaggerating the
Persona of the character are you are you
really yeah I guess yes
not by much I mean as much as you
possibly can right right and I've had
people comment but like I'm not
my commentary is not done on ones that's
like oh I'm
I'm not I guess how to phrase this I'm
not attacking addiction because of that
I'm what I am doing is I'm attacking the
things that uh Don has done or would do
uh whether or not you know on camera off
camera he is in that state of like red
eyes or he's got a little something or
you know he's like ah you know like you
know I think we all know what's going on
here and you know I think it's pretty
clear
um to what other people have reported on
and I'm just you know adding a slight
exaggeration to the character which is I
have red eyes or I've got you know Coke
on my nose
um poor Don Jr poor Don I mean I mean
there's a part there is a part of me
that looks at him like oh man it must it
must have sucked
to grow up in that that family I mean
like one it's like well probably wasn't
so bad because you were able to you know
you're given such privilege but also I
remember reports when he when when Don
uh when Donald Trump went to go pick up
Don Jr from college he slapped him
around in front of people like in front
of his in front of his uh College like
like that's the type of relationship
that uh that they have and here's the
thing I'm I'm all I'm probably gonna
safely assume that that was the same
relationship that he that Donald Trump
had with his own father because didn't
he also say I mean like Mary Trump
talked about the relationship between
her uncle and her dad and and I like I
look at that I'm like it's just a you
know it's it's uh
uh generations of abuse on a family that
is so [ __ ] up but
does not excuse certain behaviors
as adults you know right and uh so yeah
Don Jr is a complete [ __ ] uh he's a
mess he's a [ __ ] mess yeah he's what
he's what they claim uh Hunter Biden is
speaking of Don Jr uh have you guys seen
this um look at that bracket go this is
the up is this the updated one this is
the up this is day four baby this is day
four so yeah I'm speaking to Don Jr If
You're Gonna Play uh bonehead Madness
today look um Ron DeSantis is taking on
Donald Trump Jr uh in the [ __ ] waffle
um bracket here yeah to see who goes to
the uh who who plays Marjorie Taylor
green for the semifinal as you guys know
um we have bonehead Madness
maybe maybe we should just record you
should just record one uh so we have it
for uh for the championship Friday let's
get ready to rumble do you know how much
money he gets he gets paid a ton of
money to make that announcement he has
that trademarked
I should stop doing saying it yeah he'll
be sending a seasoned assist we'll have
to pay his ass we'll have to pay that
son of a [ __ ] how much does he get paid
for it dude it's uh let me look let's
get ready to rumble but anyways so so
Ted Cruz and Marjorie Taylor green have
advanced to the to what what do you call
is it the the the the
this is the deplorable four the
deplorable four so Taylor okay it says
depending on the match Michael Buffer
earns between 25
000 in a hundred thousand dollars every
time he utters those five things [ __ ]
[ __ ] me and says on a handful of uh
extremely rare occasions he's been paid
a million dollars because these are big
fights these are the big pay-per-view
the [ __ ] YouTubers they hype it up
and all that [ __ ]
iconic that's pretty sweet his son does
it too you know his son does it too oh
really oh yeah Michael Buffer well I
mean eventually you know Michael Buffer
has is like Junior I think it's Michael
Buffer Jr yeah I think it's Junior and
he does it he does it too I believe he
does the let's get ready to you know you
know what it is I don't want to have to
pay him 100 Grand right no I get it I
get it right right that but today today
for bonehead Madness you could say let's
get ready to stumble
let's get ready to stumble is that good
enough yeah yeah I feel like that would
be appropriate because like they stumble
you know these like boneheads stumble
their way in right into winning bonehead
Championship right right well speaking
is stumbling we have uh Candace Owens
and Tucker Carlson playing each other
today that's gonna be a good game I
think that's gonna be a close one some
of these have been really close some of
them are blowouts like the whole Lindsey
Graham Ted Cruz Ted Cruz whipped his ass
yeah yeah and some of these some of
these uh they start out you know
some started you know like uh I think
Candace Owens and and Charlie Kirk were
pretty close in the beginning and then
she took off I think people were like oh
[ __ ] Canada's gotta go
we're we're we're we're gonna have uh
another match today we'll we'll probably
put these games up what after the show
probably so we're looking I'll put them
up right now if you give me a minute
I'll play yeah go ahead and put them up
everyone go follow at Tony Michaels pod
that's where you can go play played the
game bonehead Madness and and pick your
winner for the game of who is the
bonehead
in the hateful eight uh advancing to the
deplorable four here as Gabe has it
named and then going to the semi-finals
um to see who wins the bonehead
championship for bonehead Madness
and this year's bonehead Madness you
guys know we do bonehead of the week and
we'll probably release that poll later
on this week I would imagine you want to
run him simultaneously we can do that
well I mean you know we we want to do a
bonehead of the week poll there'll be
plenty of boneheads to pick from this
week oh yeah I mean we already have we
already starting to Rack them up here so
by the time we get to Thursday because
that's I think that's when we we sh we
should start officially running the uh
yeah well sometime on Thursday right
we'll have two polls I'll start the last
poll of the day for this competition
will be Thursday morning okay and we'll
decide that with the next six hours and
then we'll release our actual official
head of the week normal poll right on uh
on later that day good because because
Friday just like every Friday we'll do
bonehead of the week in the second hour
of the show because we're here every
single day Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central for two hours
but on Friday in the second hour we do
bonehead of the week we go through your
vote in the poll so again don't forget
to go over at Tony Michael's pod where
you can participate in the bonehead of
the week and bonehead Madness right now
you can make your choices on who you
want the bonehead to be the bonehead
champion
I think we do this every year
yeah I'm telling you I was like I was
like oh this would be fun and I was like
oh boy uh when I first thought about it
I was like oh can I pull off 64. and
like I said yesterday it was like the
whole thing of like would people have if
there was another way to do it where
people could could compete with 64 at a
time right to begin with totally but
then I was like uh I don't know if
that's the right way to do it and it
seems like a lot yeah
and I might seem annoying so I figured
I'd just drop it down to the you know
the Sinister 16 and we'll go from there
yeah well it works it works out it works
out because there was a lot of
complaining at them at the beginning I
still like why are you putting such
boneheads against like they're all
really [ __ ] bonus right so I mean I
saw somebody uh this morning that
tweeted at us they were like oh how come
uh
how come you put Marjorie Taylor green
against Lauren bobert and I was like
dude she looks like she whipped her
well but we well I mean we we I mean we
you did put them against each other but
I mean you did how also how was I
supposed to know right
right well I mean the other one uh is
Matt gatz versus Marjorie Taylor that
really surprised me Matt Getz only got
13 right
I I figured Marjorie Taylor green and
Matt Getz that would be a close race
that would be a close race I thought I
don't know I I thought it would be
closer but you know what here's the
thing at the end of the day you know
yeah it's the beauty of the madness baby
well that may be that may be so go go
over to uh again at Tony Michaels pod
and and follow us there to play it's at
the top of the it's pinned to the top of
the the page there so you can find that
thread with all the games in it it looks
like Gabe is getting those games ready
right now so you can go vote how how
long do we have them open 16 hours 16
hours they are both both up there now so
get get get over there to at Tony
Michaels pod and uh go
go uh go vote for who you want to win in
the it's the we're in the hateful eight
right now right still is that uh we are
technically still on the hateful eight
because we have two remaining games
um to go which is uh
let's see uh here is uh let's see I'm
gonna vote here Live while we're doing
this oh boy Tony Michaels podcast day
three of the [ __ ] waffles region oh wait
day three or is it day four oh my gosh
oh no hold on oh my God hold on no no no
no wait he does this all the time folks
guys too quickly this is what happens
when you do a live you know this is he
gets he gets so in the these see people
are already voting no we're already
voting and you're messing it up here's
what he's gonna do he's gonna delete
these tweets yep so all these this this
poor sad sap that already voted is gonna
have his vote taken away from me
he used to do this all the time with
bone of the week um I used I used it I
used to put bone end of the week up and
he would he would like ah no this way
that way and it just I was like all
right you got one more shot one more
shot what what's this song uh I don't
know that's a good question what is this
song yeah all right hold on give me a
second it's technically I want to vote I
want to vote okay I'm ready to vote one
second okay give me beating down the
polls I know I know the ballots we need
the ballots the bonehead Madness ballots
get em up the digital bonehead this is
what happens when I'm trying to do it
you know I was like yeah I could do this
did you copy paste from your other one
is that what you did you copied yeah you
know what because I have I have a list
of them ready to go and I copied the
other things yeah day three instead of
day four you did that yeah right yeah
you know because it is like the first
round Chucky darn yeah I know I know I
know oh no what a bonehead oh my God I
was right I did have it right new I
think when I heard you say it
it is because I was reading day four did
you say day three or day four I said day
three yeah that's what confused me it's
game three so I thought I wrote day
three it's actually day four but game
three
did I read day three I think so
someone's gonna happen no no no no no no
no no nope we'll go back and review the
tape afterwards I read it correctly it's
probably right I probably read it wrong
yeah but uh you know it's day four
but I believe you said I think you yeah
but see look here it says welcome to day
four yeah day four the other one said
day three no no no they said game three
and I don't know I don't know yeah I
don't know everyone what do you think in
the chat who do you who do you think uh
you can't I can't wait is saying Gabe is
trying to steal the election
um and Lisa says sounds like gqp trying
to take our votes away look look all I'm
saying is stop
I was right
I don't I don't think so I think yeah it
was game three maybe it's those maybe
it's I'll even see machines
I'm looking at my spreadsheet right now
it says game three of the lame stream
media's region of business between
Tucker Carlson Kansas no it was the [ __ ]
waffles it was the [ __ ] waffle no no and
then the other one is game three of the
[ __ ] waffles regions between Iran
DeSantis and Don Trump Jr
damn it
burning time here online on live TV or
whatever both have been tweeted there we
go all right everybody everybody go
fresh to page okay
um are you gonna sub tweet these okay
here we go look look
it says now it says game three they
always said game three now it says game
three of the [ __ ] waffles region which
means Rhonda Santos and Donald Trump Jr
uh we're gonna act like none of that
happened uh maybe we'll cut it from the
uh from the um the last tape uh so that
I'm not wrong and Gabe's wrong who will
advance from the hateful eight to the
floor before comment below with your
reason hashtag bonehead Madness who am I
gonna vote for I don't know I I think I
yeah but then don't say gay Bill man I
know this one [ __ ] that that's what I
[ __ ] that's what I would do that's
what I would that's why that son of a
[ __ ] right like that it just it just
seems like that is yeah man I I mean I
mean Donald Trump Jr you know he's a
nincompoop right and I call him yeah
that's one way to put it all right well
I mean Miranda Santos at [ __ ]
that bigoted son of a [ __ ] I just it's
it's uh it's uncalled for uh this okay
game three here
of the lame stream media region is
between Tucker Carlson and Candace Owens
who advance from the hateful eight to
deplore before now here's what this is
again this is a tough one because
Candice Owens in my mind is much [ __ ]
more bone-headed than Tucker Carlson but
Tucker Carlson is much more dangerous I
feel so I'm gonna vote for Tucker here
[ __ ] Tucker Tucker sucks yep so go go
get your vote in
I retweeted these so you guys can go uh
vote for for uh boneheads I just voted
as well Boom game three
of the lame stream media region and the
[ __ ] waffles region in bone head Madness
not to be confused with uh uh March
Madness we wouldn't want to confuse it
with that yeah not to be con Atlanta and
like I said if Marjorie Taylor green
wins we'll name it Marge Madness Yeah
March Madness March Madness March
Madness Madness March Madness yes March
Madness
yeah they can't come after us for that
no absolutely not March March Madness
they they they're they don't have a
copyright right okay let's go to the
Tweety tweets and journey Trends there's
some good stuff twinning trending this
morning uh what do you think about this
uh Mick Mulvaney thing everyone wants to
boycott CBS now I mean CBS is dumb for
doing this right right yeah this is
really [ __ ] it's a dumb here's the
thing I don't have TV uh I mean I don't
have like uh cable right cable right or
satellite yeah yeah you know whatever I
I I just but CBS is a network not right
right no yeah so here's the thing I'm
not going to say like I think the
reporting is like they're they're uh
reading they're recording that like they
they write
um I think it's good obviously you know
they're reporting on a lot of the crazy
[ __ ] that's happening right now so
um
I
I'm not gonna well here's a thing good
luck boycotting CBS right okay Network
television it is Asian huge right and uh
it's a dumb this is this was a
boneheaded move so if we could if anyone
wants to tell us who the name of the
exec or the CEO of CBS uh news is or
just CBS I don't know who I'm not sure
who made the decision here if it's like
well but here's the thing here is Mick
Mulvaney is is is going to be a paid
contributor right he's hired as a paper
do you think it's a quid pro quo and
he's well I mean he's under well I don't
know I mean it could be he he is the
quid pro quo guy but he here's the thing
is he's under contract here right and
they have to pay him now for so long
because the contract whatever contract
they worked out but here's the thing
they don't have to have him on right so
like yeah they just came out right so
that's that's what everyone's saying
about boycott they just pay him out they
don't have him on
um they just they just set him on the
bench in other words they don't they
don't bring him up to bat right so so I
mean uh which is probably the good best
choice that CBS could make in this
situation is just eat their [ __ ]
sandwich pay the guy let him sit on the
bench for the time that they have on
their contract that they can
um because I'll be honest with you
I'm not happy that CBS did this because
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
this is how this is how this slow-moving
fascism leaks into the mainstream media
and this both side [ __ ] this both sides
garbage like no no no no no you don't
have to both sides everything and that
that that's not fair and balanced where
you're like oh well there's a fascist
point of view so we need to hear the
fascist point of view no no no no no no
no and to say that Mick mulmania is a
conservative is a bunch of [ __ ] too
right so
um of course Mueller she wrote if you've
ever followed uh followed Mueller she
wrote uh you'd know that she was a
government worker
and they tried to move her job across
the the country and she said Mick
Mulvaney was the architect of fire and
government employees by moving their
jobs across the country including mine
[ __ ] CPS right and that's also after
they found out that she uh
and was discussing the the reporting of
the case yeah and and she's been
interviewed on several podcasts actually
uh Bad Brad birkwood who we interviewed
last week you should go watch that
interview with Brad
um he talks about his dad Alvin but um
he interviewed
um Allison on his show so go check that
out he does a really long 360 interview
with with
um uh with her uh you know again I
understand the boycott move and all that
stuff
um the the boycott of CBS isn't going to
be successful now a real a real Power
Play would be let's hire a mick Mulvaney
and we put him on a non-compete contract
and we say we don't always have to use
you but you can't speak anywhere else oh
you're talking about CBS yeah yeah so
this would be one thing where like I
don't know if that's how the contract
was actually done I think I think that's
how most of these contributor contracts
are done is there so they're under
contract to give certain opinions about
certain things right right so yeah so
it's one of those now with that you
could potentially be like great we we
brought him on the roster no even though
he's already come forward and given a
little video talk about the tax or the
the uh tax on the wealthy mm-hmm
um you could potentially you know as CBS
say okay great yeah now that we've got
you and you've got to non-compete we're
not going to use you so now you just
have to sit and you have to wait you
know and like you have to you have to
agree to the fact that like you signed a
contract that said we could or could not
use you but you have to be ready at a
moment's notice if we need you to make
comment
and in the meantime if we don't need you
then you just have to sit over in the
corner but you can't talk about it you
can't talk about this and you can't talk
to anyone else uh on any other program
that would be another way where it's
like you could silence him that way I
don't know right why I mean that that's
that's you know sticking him on the
bench signing the old the old player and
then and then relegating him to the
bench one of your favorite guys uh here
is mad dog did you see the video of him
talking about oh yeah or some [ __ ] did
you see this yeah yeah let's let's go
see if we can find this video here I
wonder I wonder no that's not it uh
there we go Patriot takes it yeah
okay um so this is I don't is this on a
podcast or some [ __ ] I think it's a yeah
because if you look behind the other guy
it's a he's a YouTuber
oh okay oh I see I see I see when are we
gonna get our little YouTube things but
uh when you get a hundred thousand we
get silver when you get uh what the [ __ ]
everybody we need to get that little
I'll tell you what if you if you get us
to the point where we get these blacks
I'll [ __ ] make a video of me smashing
them with a hammer how's that sound I'd
smash it with a hammer I wouldn't put
him behind me I don't know I wouldn't
put the YouTube thing behind me I don't
know I think it's I think it's 100K
personal I think they'd stop sending
them if I started smashing them and once
you smash it it's done dude why no but I
mean if I smash it you think they would
send other ones if we well if we get
more because you get you know there's
like different levels yeah I mean I
think they would keep sending them
probably you know I don't know I'm just
saying well okay so we'd have to hit a
hundred thousand first to get right then
we have to hit a million to get gold and
then we have to 10 million to get
diamond and then there's this other one
that I think the only oh my God can you
imagine a video of me smashing up a
diamond whatever the hell that thing is
yeah let's do that and then the other
one is a 100 million subscribers is a
red diamond
a red diamond 100 million subscribers I
think we could get there I think we
could get the red diamond and then maybe
maybe we'd like uh go somewhere and you
know and I don't know throw it off a
[ __ ] mountain or some [ __ ] I don't
know you know make a video at it yeah
I'm just saying yeah just drop a big
Ruby diamond yeah yeah does does the
does the does it really matter like the
you know I mean if you have a hundred
thousand and they send you a plaque I
mean is it supposed to be like I don't
know it's supposed to be I mean like you
know it's on your account so no one's
gonna take that away from you but you do
have the plaque to be like well they can
they can unsubscribe well yeah but
you're gonna have to have that many
people unsubscribed so I guess you
really do need the plaque then you need
the plaque I guess okay or you have the
video of the proof that you had the
black they used right right you're like
look it says Tony Michael's podcast
right here okay [ __ ] right yeah
you know maybe we'd saw it in half or I
I don't know I don't know I'm just I'm
just making obseries here uh Patriot
takes uh
he and types Madison Catherine affirms
Washington DC is like a movie house of
cards they really are obsessed with
[ __ ] TV shows and movies aren't they
and said people and that he's looked up
his whole life who are now in their 60s
and 70s have invited him to ordies at
their home and others have done cone
cocaine in front of him okay number one
I've watched this video I've watched
this already and we're gonna play a bit
of it here
here's the thing they watch way too many
[ __ ] fictional things right [ __ ]
they get [ __ ] reality and fiction
confused a lot and it's obvious but
here's here's the thing I don't know man
I don't I don't think any any [ __ ]
any [ __ ] Democrat would invite this
person to anything yeah we we we know
where the party or like we we know who's
having or rather which party is having
the party Oh you mean political party
yeah
orgy cocaine drug parties because what
he says he's pretty revealing in I
highly doubt because he says he looks
like in the clip he says he looks up to
these people right and he like looked at
him growing up and I highly doubt they
were Democrats that he was looking up so
you're saying he might have looked up to
Barack Obama is that what you're saying
oh yeah totally or looked up to Hunter
Biden he probably looks up the hunter
Biden you know but I look at this and
I'm like one I wouldn't be surprised if
these things actually exist exist and
they actually happen and two I think
he's full of [ __ ] I don't know man I
mean I want I want it to be real that
that a bunch of [ __ ] 60 and 70-year
Republicans are having [ __ ] orgies
together and and why man that sounds
really cool and all but I think he's
full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
I think he's just trying to create this
clip so we'll play it right well here's
well okay play the clip and I'll say
what I've said right about to get
serious yes I am with uh Kevin he even
says he's bound to get serious like oh
we're gonna forget who else we're gonna
drop the news um but a really well done
show very well done very well done show
but it was so dirty and it was about
this Congressman
oh it's so dirty
what the [ __ ] is wrong with these people
[ __ ] head out of your ass it's
acting like you
some kind of Angels or something get the
[ __ ] out of here you're getting invited
to orgies
majority whip yeah what was it yeah and
so anyway very very powerful guy
powerful and it was just kind of like
his secret life of all this corruption
it was a TV show it's just dirty's house
because you're you've been behind the
veil is this uh fictitious show can you
imagine can you imagine like Madison
Gotham actually probably would watch at
an orgy behind a veil yeah don't you
think like oh you've been like well I
just wonder if it is that you know uh uh
what was that what was that Hollywood
movie about the [ __ ] sex orgy like
the elite one with the Tom Cruise with
uh oh and yeah I know Eyes Wide Shut
yeah that's it there we go yeah yeah I
just imagine like you know you've got
one of these little masks on and it's
like I wonder who this guy could be do
you think you think Madison got Thorne's
Eyes Wide Shut mask had a Hitler
mustache on the bottom of it like it was
probably like a little little broomstick
down there yeah I don't know I just
maybe wouldn't even go to the orgy and
Heaven
I was like I don't want anyone to
recognize who I am someone out there
with some graphics yeah make us a
graphic that shows what Madison Gotham
would look like with his orgy mask or is
this more closer to like a documentary
is it that bad so I heard a form of
president that we had in the 90s was
asked the question so which one there
were two right right right that that
when I heard when I heard this I'm like
he says former president who
yeah you know he's talking to you is
there is there like evidence of this of
Bill Clinton being asked this question
uh uh because it wasn't let me search
for this in an incognition window
but you don't want someone showing up at
your doorstep yeah look how do we know
how also how do we know it wasn't George
H.W no come on man how do you know no
one would ask H.W bush if he was having
an order here's the thing I mean
you could you could say it was Bill
Clinton right and if he's trying to make
some sort of like uh Epstein connection
right right well if he's making an
Epstein connection the guy that he
claims is his is his long-lost father
that he talks to every day on the phone
two or three times a day yeah but he
wasn't Steam and Epstein orgies for
[ __ ] for [ __ ] sake let me let me look
up George Bush
George H.W bush yeah HW there's no
evidence I'll keep playing while you're
looking he gave an answer that I thought
was so true and he said the only thing
that's not accurate in that show is that
you could never get a piece of
legislation about about education passed
that quickly
and everything else is good aside from
that I mean
so here's the other thing that I cut
this is the other thing that makes me
think it is Bill Clinton is because
Hillary tried to pass an education bill
right when they were in office
and uh so it I don't know I I don't
think any there's anything about H.W
bush it's obviously these are all
allegations but like he's uh he's I
don't know it makes it seem like he was
talking to uh Bill Clinton
right well let's let's listen to what he
Washington I mean being kind of a young
guy in Washington remember the average
age of probably 60 or 70.
and I look at all these people a lot of
them that I you know I've looked up to
through my life I've always paid
attention to politics guys you know like
Barack Obama
Chuck Schumer you know all these
Democrats that he looked up to and he
really idolized his whole life right
mm-hmm okay then all of a sudden you get
invited to like well hey we're gonna
have kind of a sexual get-together at
one of our homes you should come they're
like who who says that yeah
maybe it's because they're 60 and 70
that they use such formal language to be
like hey I was wondering if you like to
participate in some intercourse with
with me and some other individuals at a
formal dinner party yeah right listen if
you would come if you would like to show
up to my uh my sleeping quarters we will
have a sexual intercourse of sorts okay
Amy Tony Baron listen listen yeah now
you know it's [ __ ] Republicans
because a Democrat would be like hey you
want to come over and you know [ __ ] a
bunch of people hang on come on have a
[ __ ] order you trying to [ __ ] like
that's that's what I would say but yeah
when I look at Republicans I say yeah
he's so formal it's like oh listen oh my
God
we're gonna have
have you have you ever read the book how
to have oh my god let's let's finish
with this absolute dribble
what what did you just ask me to come to
yeah and then you realize they're asking
you to come to an orgy yeah uh or the
fact that you know there's some of the
people that are leading on the movement
to try and remove you know Addiction in
our country and then you watch them
doing it I'll keep up with cocaine right
in front of you and it's like wow this
is this is wild about to get serious
this is this is wild give me a bump this
is this is crazy stuff I'm digging it
let's yeah let's go so you know I I look
at this and it's like you know maybe
it's you know I don't know maybe he's uh
maybe he's telling the truth maybe he's
exaggerating either way he threw the
Republican Party under the [ __ ] bus
because he didn't even know it he didn't
even know like he's like I'm gonna I'm
gonna make some great content here right
and everyone's gonna think that it's the
the cabal Democrats that are doing this
right like the sexual deviants because
they they do that with AOC they like
make her into like this sexual deviant
or something and then and then on the
other hand they're like oh she's really
gross and have you seen her her her
blumpkin boyfriend or whatever that you
know whatever they make they're like oh
he's wearing open-toed sandals all right
why are you guys so obsessed with feet
dude right dude they're they're [ __ ]
weird if you have a fetish that's
totally cool you know they're more
obsessed they're more obsessed with feet
than they are genitalia in bathrooms
yeah they really aren't they they're
like oh give me that big toe
um so I look at this and I'm like I
don't know
I don't know if it's real I I want to
actually believe that it's real and he
is
he's that dumb that uh
that he would just say it and now Kevin
McCarthy was like I'm gonna talk to him
he said he said I'm gonna I'm there a
video of this
we're gonna catch it if there is we're
gonna go to it here uh but he said I'm
gonna talk to him and what's funny about
that is like it was it took this
interview for Kevin MacArthur to be like
hey hey that's way too far that's way
too far Insurrection overturning the
Constitution I'm gonna talk to him about
that and you're like wait so that's all
it took it
orgies and like the origins of this okay
so now I am actually believing that this
is happening now I'm actually believing
now I'm believing what he's saying is
true now that you're saying that Kevin
McCarthy actually said he had to have a
talk with him uh Ted Lou here said of
course everyone knows Ted Lou is the uh
Democratic representative from
California he said based on the
interview of the GOP rep Madison Gotham
I just have to say wow the G the House
GOP caucus is much wilder than I thought
um
it's it's so thank you Ted Lou for uh
giving us insight into
um what the Democratic caucus does and
does not do
but apparently Ted luge never heard of
uh Washington orgies you sent a link
here what's this link here this is uh
uh uh this is Tyler we're reporting on
based on Politico
um
of Kevin McCarthy saying that
he
he uh
uh so Justin is this uh this is no this
is not too long a couple hours ago I got
another one for you breaking news
another one for you that's okay that is
uh it's from political I was looking for
the article to find a political and then
I found this other one but let's talk
about this first and then I got this
other one that uh okay good just in
several Republicans say they're upset
they're upset they're just upset they're
not when you talk about the sex parties
bro dude shut the [ __ ] up man dude shut
up lay low on the sexual get-togethers
okay
um that Madison got there and said his
Republican colleagues had invited him
into cocaine orgies no that's not what
he said exactly Brian he said sexual
get-togethers is what I said um and
where they did where they did have
cocaine orgies but right sexual one
Republican said people are now asking
who is partaking in orgies who are these
60 and 70 year old sexual get-together I
think I don't know I think there's just
a bunch of 69 year old people wait right
well
so not not 68 not 70.
69. okay good
and if they're 68 then they're like oh I
you know I brought up I brought a friend
so right there right there yeah
um Kevin McCarthy plans to talk to uh
cawthorne about it plans to cut what is
he talk to him about what is he gonna be
like so where are these parties yeah
why haven't I gotten in right right
where are these happening at where
exactly and what time is there a certain
day do we have like a schedule that you
can give me right um he's apparently
going to talk
to Madison like this is what it took for
him to talk
to anyone right like they're like
Insurrection nah all right
oh my God these [ __ ] okay let's see
this next one here uh see what you got
on this next one let's see here what do
we get
um this is a Politico
oh what what what
yeah well what is this what what the
[ __ ] is this is this is this new yeah
this is from like 15 minutes ago okay so
so
did you did you do this does Daniel Dale
need do we need a page Daniel no I
haven't no I wasn't this is an actual
interview I haven't seen any press oh
okay I didn't know I didn't know
or not look there I don't know maybe
there's a press release coming out later
today I don't know but what I am saying
is that this is an actual interview this
is an annual interview with just the
news where it's president former Donald
Trump
in an interview called on a Russian uh
President Vladimir Putin to release
information regarding alleged dealings
with Eastern Europe oligarchs and Hunter
Biden so is this like Russia if you're
listening listening yeah is that what
this is
Hunter Baden
aren't you bad in that's what I yeah
he's like listen Putin if you're
listening tell Matthew I'm too bad in I
mean that's obviously more of a of a Don
Junior asking for these things but it
says uh in making his claims about
Hunter Biden Trump's cited the findings
of a controversial highly politicized uh
investigation by Senate Republicans into
the bidens which was published just
weeks before the 2020 election and
produced little new evidence of
wrongdoing
so Putin's getting his ass kicked in
Ukraine right uh getting his [ __ ] ass
dumped yeah he's on the verge of having
to get in a bunker and probably eat a
bullet
um you know or take a the bio or sign it
whatever whatever you however you choose
he might cheers his way to death I don't
know right he might he might go with a
neck rash there's a lot of things that
you could do in a bunker to make sure
that you are not
um uh held accountable for your war
crimes but
uh Donald Trump here thinks that
Vladimir Putin's number one concern is
to make sure that he protects Donald
Trump's reputation his criminal
reputation in this country to release
dirt on Hunter Biden's laptop or what
whatever the [ __ ] it is whatever the
hell they're talking about here because
the distraction is 100 bite because it
was Joe Biden you remember that remember
that when they when they wanted the
president zielinski the guy who is who
is uh heroically defending his country
his democracy the democratically elected
president who's who's trying his
damnedest defend off a murderous [ __ ]
dictator he's committing war crimes
against his citizens and his kind and
his Sovereign Nation
that guy that guy was bullied to try to
get to release dirt on on Joe Biden
during the election and now now that
Trump is has painted himself into a
criminal corner here in more ways than
one not just not just on January 6 not
just in New York but in Georgia and
other places this guy's gonna call on
Putin
call on Putin to release I don't know
dirt on Hunter Biden I guess like they
and they think that Hunter Biden has
like more dirt than they already post on
the internet I seen a picture the other
day where they're at someone claimed it
was a picture of Hunter Biden snorting
cocaine off a [ __ ] ass and I was like
what the hell's that what what I mean
why is that any different than Don Jr
posting any video that he post on
Facebook
the uh here I got the video I'm not
gonna I don't want us to go to the
website for all the other dumb ass [ __ ]
so I'm gonna bring up this video
and uh we'll watch what Trump said
oh okay yeah go ahead let me uh let me
pull this the mayor of moscow's wife
give the bidens to both of them goodbye
dance
[Laughter]
she gave him three and a half million
dollars
so now I would think Putin would know
the answer to that I think he should
release it I think we should know that
answer
so yeah that was on the real America's
voice oh yeah because you know we should
really trust that
for sure so that's the
Trump this is a moment where Trump is
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] is hitting the wall
and it's or it's hitting a fan going
against the wall there's all this stuff
that's happening right I I need to throw
out like the other thing too is he's
giving these he's these rallies right
he's giving these speeches at these
rallies and he's just dropping f-bombs
like without without filter he's just
like dropping him here he's kind of
stealing our [ __ ] game you know what
I mean but I'm also like uh is he you
know like cognitively is he kind of just
like going down where he he doesn't like
does he one not care anymore or two is
he just not even aware that he's saying
it right well no I think the whole point
is is that he's he's trying to appeal to
the worst of the worst because he thinks
they're going to protect him like he he
believes that that the worst of the
worst are going to protect him we are 30
minutes into the second hour um let's go
back to the tweets I wanna I I I like
that story but I do want to
um speaking of trump did you know
there's a new member of the Trump family
did you know that there is a baby no not
a bait well sort of oh you're talking
about this uh I'm talking about Kevin
you're talking about this this Freudian
slip what uh no I'm talking about Kelly
and Trump did they get married I I don't
know
we're gonna see here let's launch Sean
Hannity better Mr speaker thank you for
being with us here now with more
reaction former Council to the president
kellyanne Trump along with former
Arkansas Governor Mike Huckabee Fox News
oh my God Mike Huckabee holy [ __ ] okay
okay no no okay so wait a second here
let's let's let's concentrate on the new
member of the Trump family doesn't she
really look like she's done like a whole
Ivanka Trump plastic surgery thing
possibly I mean she definitely do you
think that's why Sean Hannity got
confused maybe I mean this this does not
look like I mean this does not look like
the kellyanne Conway that we normally we
come to know
she's like it almost looks like she
wants she's she's trying to look like
Madonna almost is that what it is I
don't know is that what Madonna looks
like now I don't know I don't know I'm
not sure but like it I'm just getting I
don't know in my mind I'm getting that
sense that that's what she's trying to
go for
um what about the Utah bomber here in
the middle what's the oh God I did not
even recognize that was Mike Huckabee
like did he stop was he dying his beard
in his hair before like I I don't know I
don't remember him ever being like
Santa Gray
well I mean dudes get old well I get
that dudes get old but I did it's like
during the pandemic hold on hold on hold
maybe this is pandemic Mike Huckabee
like still like he's still doing the
whole pandemic thing
this is this is something else this is
wild oh you know what it's because he
didn't have oh you know what's throwing
me off it's the fact that he didn't have
a beard before right on top of that I
think he was dying his hair slightly to
not to not just do like uh
uh gray hair but he was like it was like
a you know like a darker not like a
peppered kind of look all right well I I
I think maybe maybe uh Mike Huckabee is
trying to do the whole Don Jr thing you
know Don Jr grew a bitter beard to make
himself feel tough Eric Trump has kind
of done the same thing these all all
these guys are kind of grown beards to
make their you know they're manly right
Macho they're machismo they got I think
how does that make you feel as someone
who can grow a beard because I'm like
yeah so so how does that make you feel
as a man with a beard you're you're
you're so so that's it just yeah like my
my uh beard growing ability is more like
uh Gruff okay I can't grow a full beard
right yes I'm admitting to the people
out there I cannot
all the trolls all the trolls are gonna
come in and really douse you now and
which is like good and bad you know but
at the same time so I you know I don't
think it's like Scruff on the sides it
has grown in more over time you know I
got this baby face going on over here
right but for someone who actually can
go beard like yourself right you know do
you look at this and you're like oh this
is an insult for all these guys who are
growing beards it looks I tell you I
tell you where you guys look bad I tell
you what's an insult to beards it's Ted
Cruz's beard this oh [ __ ] yeah well he
needs to [ __ ] learn how to trim that
bastard you need to learn how to diet it
looks like [ __ ] I mean you know my [ __ ]
could be here I'm you know I I [ __ ]
hate this son of a [ __ ]
um he's a piece of garbage but
for for it an old dude's beard this
isn't bad you know like the coloring is
you know consistent right um you know
he's really got the old grandpa Santa
Claus look going
um so it's not a bad beard it's not a
great one but it's not a bad beard uh
Ted Cruz is a disgrace to beards if you
you know you know what he reminds me of
and I could be totally wrong on this
uh
uh he reminds me a little bit of Ernest
Hemingway you think so I think so he
probably would not probably not his
longer thing but like if I look at
Ernest Hemingway and is like you know
photos online I see the ones of him in
color you know he's got a little beard
going on it's got a little shorter hair
on top you know balding whatever it kind
of makes me think of earnest anyway you
know uh I don't mean to insult Ernest
Hemingway right yeah but yeah he's
seriously on Earnest okay the appearance
I mean yes I also come from the same
Hometown that Ernest Hemingway grew up
in so right
so I'm seriously when I said it's pretty
pretty close here's here's Paul's uh
comparison here of how the kellyanne
Conley really is trying to look like
Ivanka Trump I think but he says uh oh
better get makeup
I don't know if you guys know who Mako
is but it's the the the the budget the
budget uh uh car
um paint company right and then when
Mako is
um but we see Kelly and Conway here
obviously this is from the White House
days to uh Sean Hannity Show I could see
how he got confused I really could right
I really could see how he got confused
yeah there's a there's a lot going on
there uh you know maybe it's more than
just ironing hair I'm not sure thank you
Paul for situating this out so now we
know why he was confused okay Kelly and
Trump Jesus [ __ ] Christ what in the
actual hell is going on what timeline
are we in okay the other the other thing
that's in the news
um is the FDA
um this is important news there's not
much though the second booster right
yeah yeah the breaking news is that uh
U.S Regulators have authorized uh
another covid-19 booster uh of Pfizer
and moderna both uh for people over 50
and older and also uh in immune
compromised uh folks and I think there's
a list of what those I mean compromised
you know do you know why this do you
want to know the reason why this is go
ahead yeah it's because we don't have
enough to pay for a fourth shot if we
need it
so right now we have to prioritize like
there was a report that came out
recently what what do you what who
doesn't have of the U.S you mean from
the bills the uh funds that we've
already appropriated right we don't have
enough for a fourth round for everyone
for everyone so now we have to
prioritize people above the age of 50
and those who are um immunocompromised I
got you I get you so that's that's where
the U.S regulations so other countries
which I'm like yeah please give it to
other countries clearly it's gonna go to
waste here since not everyone's gonna
take it but uh other countries are now
getting themselves uh uh uh higher on
the list to receive
um vaccines so you're saying we're going
to be sending Pfizer and moderna so it
doesn't go bad to other countries
because I don't know if we'll be sending
them but it will be the price I thought
we bought enough to have four doses in
that not enough for everyone okay well
uh but no I what I don't know if they're
going to take it off the shelf and then
ship it over I think what's on the Shelf
is on the shelf or what's in the
refrigerators and the refrigerators but
it's coming straight from the facilities
of those pharmaceutical companies to say
like okay you guys ordered this batch
you'll get it as opposed to it's here
and they were like wow
ship it from the Shelf you know the good
news is they're still staying on top of
this coronavirus thing right
um so that that way people aren't just
thinking oh it's all over you know and
over with and done they're trying to
stay on top of make sure that we're all
protected here of course you know maybe
we'll have a trucker's Convoy for this
fourth dose though I have some sport are
they still up there are they still doing
that yeah so we still have the Convoy
people we still have the JFK Junior
people in Dallas right I mean we've got
we've got the crazies everywhere I don't
know are they still hold up in that
hotel they were holed up in a hotel in
Dallas
um is that the same group that was uh
that was sipping that those chemicals
the the what no well they were drinking
piss no no no no no there was a group of
JFK Junior people oh supporters who were
drinking this other like chemical for
poisoning
because they had coveted or they were
trying to like prevent it no I I don't
know you know I thought they were
drinking piss I thought they were I mean
they were drinking piss they were
drinking piss but there was another
group of them who were drinking
um oh so there's the piss the piss JFK
Drinkers and then there's another one
yeah yeah
okay well yeah uh yep yep
[Music]
uh let's see Dallas Cuban on cult leader
is using indoctrinated kids to spread uh
spread his ideas on live streams oh [ __ ]
of course uh
um as you're looking that up I'm looking
here
um of course
um
yeah they're drinking toxic chemicals
um industrial bleach chlorine dioxide
um
I mean these people are just like
killing themselves literally
uh but I haven't
I haven't seen anything recently okay
there was a an article two weeks ago
about Dallas Q Anon cult leader is using
indoctrinated kids to spread his ideas
on on live streams that was March 14th
but I haven't seen anything
uh
after that the stuff before that is the
stuff in December where they were
drinking these toxic industrial cleaner
I get you industrial cleaner so Merit
Garland is now trending at 29
um
it looks like a federal judge
um
um they're they're asking the question
when will Mary Garland let's bring this
up here didn't they just appoint like
130 lawyers on this case though
so here's here's the thing is that
Merrick Garland is not going to show his
[ __ ] cards like I understand that
everyone wants this to happen yesterday
right now politically
uh you don't want to really start this
prosecution in this process till like
summer right
um until after the midterms because you
don't want these people uh you know
claiming oh I I don't like Trump I don't
like Trump ever right no we want these
people we want these trumpers to win
these primaries folks because we want
them to have to stand behind this
criminal activity
I mean I'm telling you politically
um everyone thinks politically that this
is that it is it is needs to happen now
which it does but more likely the most
damage to be possible
mid-summer yeah so you're thinking next
summer no this summer this is Summer
Okay this summer is when uh so we're
we're months upon it but Merrick Garland
is not and I know I don't know if that's
gonna happen what I'm saying is the most
politically damaging for Donald Trump
trumpism and Republicans in this country
who want us to have a fascist State who
are trying to attempt to soft coo like
Matt Getz described
um at their last Nazi excuse me Trump
rally right um uh he described that he
was going to make Donald Trump speaker
of the house and they were going to
impeach and make him king or whatever
the [ __ ] they think
but at the most politically damaging
um things that need to happen are this
summer right why do you think the
January 6 elect committee isn't like
just rolling out the [ __ ] carpet here
is because they're going their goal is
to damage trumpism that's their whole
[ __ ] goal they said it last night
I'll play Jamie you're asking here in a
minute but everyone's questioning mayor
Garland this morning and again I said
this last week
um when we had Pope on
is that questioning mayor Garland fine
whatever you can do that Merrick Garland
is not the one that's going to prosecute
the case in Washington D.C he's the
Attorney General of the United States
he's not he is not the prosecutor at the
DC at the DC Court he's not now he is he
is his boss right but Merrick Garland
isn't going to personally prosecute the
case against Donald Trump nor will he
make the final decision probably rather
to indict him or not I mean he will give
his advice he will be briefed on that
but he will probably not be given the
final decision rather he is to prosecute
Trump or not it will probably come down
to the United States Attorney uh the
prosecutor in that office now
when you question the institution of the
Department of Justice in this moment
and your your aim is for
authoritarianism where you just convict
someone right now no matter what because
we have to have it because if we don't
have it it's bad that that is what Bill
Barr that's the type of [ __ ]
Department of Justice that bill Barr was
running we do not want that in our
democratic system democracy is so much
more important than having Donald Trump
being indicted today like he's gonna be
indicted somewhere it's gonna happen and
it's probably going to be multiple
jurisdictions multiple indictments but
listen it is so more important for us to
maintain us to be a democracy not an
autocracy that is very important so
questioning the institutions themselves
is very dangerous and wanting
authoritarianism just for the sake of
getting rid of authoritarianism is just
as dangerous so so be careful with this
uh and I and I and I empathize with with
everyone out there absolutely hey why is
is happening fast enough it's like yeah
we I mean we if we saw four years of of
red flags you know even before but we
saw red flags along the way and we're
like what the [ __ ] why is this happening
obviously because certain protective
measures are in place by Republicans
having the final say or votes or
whatever and now that it's like oh [ __ ]
all this stuff is coming to light and
we're actually seeing the the terrible
things that were done especially when it
comes to January 6th it's like yo the
house is [ __ ] burning let's deal with
it and it's like hold on hold on let's
assess to know where the fire is coming
from first you know and I I totally get
people that are that are getting
impatient because they're like oh whoa
we're watching this thing happen in real
time why does anyone do anything
meanwhile it's like well before we go
and make a case for it or or prosecute
we want to make sure that we have
everything lined up because God forbid
we we we stumble
and falter and make a mistake and then
now the whole case is uh gets thrown out
and there's a mistrial or whatever
because
um Somebody went too fast or there was
some conflict of interest or there was
this or that or whatever it is oh that
would be way worse right and then you're
like well you got away with it because
right you know because people wanted it
right away it's like well because it
keeps doing patient for for them it is
it is and and hear me when I say this it
is better for them not to be prosecuted
than to be prosecuted and get away with
this right that that it it is it is way
worse for them to get prosecuted and get
away with this because they will use
that as a wedge to keep their fascism
going yeah um here's here's the video of
last night
I don't know if you guys seen this this
is a very powerful video
um it's got a it's got almost a million
views now
um it's a very powerful video of
Representative Jamie Raskin of Maryland
um he is uh part of the January 6 select
committee last night they had a vote to
advance
uh the contempt vote to the floor for
damn Dan scavino and Peter Navarro of
not cooperating with the January 6th
select committee they're going to hold
them uh in while they're going to advise
the doj to hold them in criminal
contempt of congress right um that that
I'm not sure exactly when that vote will
go to the floor probably sometime uh in
the early part of next week I would I
would imagine I don't know what their
floor schedule looks like but that's
probably when they'll vote on this of
course it'll pass and go to the doj
we're still waiting on the contempt
charges of Mark Meadows but I would
imagine that the the reason why we're
waiting on criminal charges for that is
because of a voter fraud charges
possibly in North Carolina so yeah but
let's listen to Jamie Raskin here what
he has to say about it would it would be
it would be very interesting if they if
they use the voter fraud charges and
January 6th as either leverage for
for charges to be like if you uh
cooperate with us and you provide
materials willingly right then we might
uh look the other way or that is how it
works that's how it works when you do
plea deals and you do negotiations with
prosecutors is a lot of times they give
you leniency on other charges that may
be more damaging and may give you more
prison time other than a contempt of
congress charge here's Jamie Raskin on
Dan scavino and more importantly he's
talking about Peter Navarro here who
constantly goes on bannon's Trader TV
his body is let's listen podcast and he
makes noises about the next Insurrection
a year after the election was over he
said if they want an Insurrection they
keep pushing this they're going to push
the American people over the freaking
Edge
Mr chairman Madam Vice chair the
American people opposed the January 6th
Insurrection and the American people
oppose future insurrections and coups
against our government we are fighting
to defend the institutions and values of
democracy at home against coup plotters
and insurrectionists and we are
supporting other democracies around the
world Under Siege by autocrats and
kleptocrats bullies and despots we are
on the side of the people of Ukraine
against Vladimir Putin who is not a
genius but a mass murderer and we stand
strong on the side of democracy Freedom
the Constitution and the rule of law
against people who smashed our police
officers in the face with confederate
battle flags and tried to cancel out the
results of our presidential election
these two men are in contempt of
congress and we must cite them both for
their Brazen disregard for their duties
and for our laws and our institutions
woo
God damn that's what I said God damn
because that's about the only response
that I actually had when he slam dunked
these [ __ ] in the trash
um Jim you're asking does not mince
words um often uh he does not hold back
and I think for him too like you know
he's there there is uh you know
um
I think he feels like a sense of
responsibility right like he was there
for you know holding uh the trial you
know because that's what it was
um
against Trump on you know his for
impeachment right around January 6th so
it's like
I think whether he looks at this as an
opportunity to redeem himself or the
country for letting this guy get away
with it because Republicans even though
they said you know right after like
Mitch McConnell they they voted they
said nope Trump is okay we're not going
to impeach him or we're not gonna you
know uh yeah we're not gonna impeach him
um Mitch McConnell gave a vote and was
like uh so yeah we all agree it was
Trump's fault but uh
We're Not Gonna I'm not gonna throw them
out right right so well I mean this is
the Republican way here's here's another
goddamn this is this is RNC this is the
official RNC research account
yeah the people that want Putin in power
right it says Biden again says Putin
shouldn't remain in power so like what's
wrong with that well right but listen
listen to this video listen to this
question
it means that I would hopefully I just
it was expressing my outrage he
shouldn't remain in power just like you
know bad people shouldn't continue to do
bad things but it doesn't mean we have a
fundamental policy to do anything to
take Putin down in any way
whoosh so the Republicans are saying oh
my God it's bad that Joe Biden doesn't
want Putin in power this is the same
[ __ ] you're talking about the same exact
[ __ ] you're talking about by the way
let's [ __ ] your Tweet sucks I figured
out what word it is
it sucks because I tweet the [ __ ] list
in the other one right yeah it's such a
bad word sucks is a bad word Twitter
twitter.com you know what's funny about
this you you say this to her you like
let's say that there was a republican
person online and you said you suck
right right and uh
uh you've got Twitter who comes forward
and says hey man you sure you want to
say that like might come off and you're
like okay whatever you might hurt them
yeah yeah and then the person that
receives it goes hmm that's not nice
that's mean hey I'm gonna block you or
Twitter you should I'm gonna report them
you should ban them right right
meanwhile they on the flip side go you
[ __ ] bleep bleep bleep bleep bleep
whatever online and they're like don't
censor me right or yeah
right and so it's like which is it dude
and 90 seconds they suck they suck those
guys suck these guys suck we all know
they suck that's why it sucks to suck
because we know your ideas suck and you
know that we know that your ideas suck
all right well no their ideas suck for
average Americans their ideas don't suck
for the rich and Powerful all right you
know yeah well uh let's let me go um
we're 52 minutes in the hour I want to
go to
um
um the gym you're asking uh thread here
because I think it's worthy here uh and
I believe there is oh oh no dunking on
Marjorie Taylor how could I actually
come on
Jack you got me in a bind here
you got me in a bind like I wanted to
move on to some other things but he says
this is a clip of Jamie raskins contempt
of congress oh boy okay so this is this
is yeah it's a while back I can't resist
I gotta watch this video it's government
but somehow the Communists here in
charge have forgotten forgotten or
purposely abusing the Constitution and
what this this body of Congress is
supposed to do through equality under
the law and we are not Communists as the
gentlelady from Georgia suggested that's
just the Friends of the former president
who you lionize like the dictator of
North Korea who he loves and Vladimir
Putin who said that the greatest tragedy
of the 20th century was the collapse of
the Soviet Union so those are your
friends don't put them on our side
they're saying that
and he's like anyway moving on all right
so anyway anyways anyways as I was as I
was saying before I was rudely
interrupted thank thank you Jack for
your tweet I really do appreciate it um
if you come up with more Clips like that
please please uh sprinkle them
throughout the trends um because that
was that was a pleasant surprise there
I'm looking for what I'm looking for is
uh maybe maybe what I should do is go to
uh Peter Navarro thread here
the reason why is because
um
did I spell it right do I got it right
there
yes nav
n-a-v-a-r-r yeah rrl okay uh here's
here's what I really want to see is this
[ __ ] bonehead uh because he claims
that he can't he can't uh go before the
select committee right and the reason
why they're holding him in contempt
is because here it is multiple media
appearance here it is
um
um Stephanie Murphy here is
representative Stephanie Murphy here
shows at the hearing last night I'm not
gonna play this whole video because
we're a little impressed on time but she
says hey he's been on media and here's a
a video of him being on uh Ari Melbourne
uh to share with you about what what I
was involved in and what I know given
that you've told me
that you have a plan that you push to
delay or deal with the certification you
told me 100 members back it and you've
said in public he keeps he keeps saying
you've told me like you said it out loud
right here on the show I'm not making it
up man you just told me right and he
actually actually at one point in this
clip he like plays Black back a clip of
like earlier of like 10 minutes before
when he was telling him the [ __ ] that
he's saying that you're telling me I'm
sure the people in the booth were like
they were like all right get these clips
ready because he's about to talk yeah
this motherfucker's gonna dispute what
he just said
if you say all those things out here
why risk a legal battle or going to jail
to refuse to discuss them with the
committee under oath
because I have a loyalty to the
Constitution and a loyalty to the
president then you wouldn't say them on
TV you dumb [ __ ] right you
wouldn't say I'm on TV so what are you
like a loyalty to the Constitution it's
like if you had a loyal to the
Constitution then you wouldn't have
attempted treason right well well I mean
you also you also would not you would
not defy a constitutional order right
that is a subpoena from Congress to
testify right about these events that
they're one also what happened to
country over party like if you really
cared about that you really think this
guy cares about country party but what
I'm saying is like you know as someone
like
that's that's their [ __ ] that
statement is a contradiction because
he's saying that he believed he's a you
know a defender or believer in the
Constitution and the president it's like
no no like yes you can believe in both
but you following one guy like a cult
negates the other one is that what he
means by loyalty is it is
yeah it's a [ __ ] cult it's a [ __ ]
cult I've said it before but it is let's
listen to Ari slam down game again the
president has invoked executive
privilege in this matter it's not
um
uh to uh revoke that privilege you say
it's not your privilege to wave but
let's look look at how often you've
waived it let's look at some of the news
this is it watch this on these topics
take a look former Trump advisor Peter
Navarro is spilling that that
watch watch now now it's different this
is crazy this is like picture-in-picture
type right right so so like Ari's this
is a different yeah podcast obviously
because this is
changes now change is close
he has his like rolled up sleeves and
like I I can't remember I can't remember
who he reminds me of but it's Navarro
yeah yeah this is style that he has
where it's like it's it's Kramer that
that the guy that that's what it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the whole [ __ ]
thing yeah what's his name Jim is it Jim
Cramer yeah and a [ __ ] idiot yeah the
MSNBC you
congressmen and Senators on Capitol Hill
ready to implement the sweep Peter
Navarre implement the suite that's
that's the whole football thing they
think they're cool because they had a
they had the football thing but here he
is here he is on Steve bannon's Trader
TV now if you notice Peter Navarro is
patiently waiting over here in the
corner waiting on this us tells Pence to
take they got the football in the
background look at that hotel's Rolling
Stone it was about look at the football
thing in the back what the [ __ ] is why
does he have the football thing in the
back background all these [ __ ] clowns
man you can't make this [ __ ] up like
literally if you were gonna clown these
[ __ ] and you're gonna make fun
of them acting like the the coup was a
football play you would put a football
scene behind you on a green screen to
make fun of them the only thing I would
do that would and well I don't know why
I didn't think of this at the time but
if I were to do a uh video about this I
would try to go and I'd like have the
Whiteboard and I'd go so listen we got
the capital here and we got our friends
and we're gonna drive up the middle and
we're gonna go here we need a block okay
we need a block from the tight end you
know and then it's like I just I just
see that as the it's just the possible
one where it's like let's you know just
like John Madden there we go up the
middle for the touchdown you know or
like we go for the extra point blocked
you know obviously here again you see
they're back to Ari and on his own
broadcast like he's like hey dude you
were on my [ __ ] show Ariane would
decertify the election
how do you expect people to take
seriously your claim that this is secret
and privileged when you've been out
there talking about it and when you and
Bannon said the committee's dog wouldn't
bark they were afraid of you and the
report it seems now Peter like the dog
is Bart
oh that's [ __ ] fantastic thank thank
you Aaron for sharing that video we are
we are 59 minutes into the hour we're
coming to a close here remember tomorrow
is Wednesday hump day hump day and we've
got we've got more bonehead Madness
games going on all week yeah so go to uh
Tony Michael's bod on on the Tweety
tweets and the journey Trends to follow
the bonehead man this game's also follow
me at Tony Michaels and follow Gabe at I
am Gabe Sanchez
and don't forget to download the podcast
everyone's we got a lot of new downloads
a lot of new listeners Gabe a lot I just
want to say hello hello to all the new
listeners out there Apple Spotify you're
the the most the most boycotted
um uh uh uh the directory out there
Spotify Apple Google wherever you get
your podcast Go download a podcast give
us a five star review there not a four
star five star five star review tell us
what you think one go to YouTube
subscribe yeah go to the YouTube channel
subscribe to the YouTube channel don't
miss anything every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central and if you do miss it
you can go over to YouTube channel and
re-watch right there as soon as we're
done it's there it's there for you to
watch and then as you're on Facebook
like us share us on Facebook
and we're on the mind is touch Facebook
page now
broadcasting live not just YouTube
Twitter twitch game baby we're doing it
all we're meta now we are totally meta
welcome to the metaverse that is that
what it is that what it's called I mean
no metaverse is the one where they're
all avatars I would love to see our
characters as avatars or just like
[ __ ] talking where we're in the we're
in the members yeah but that requires
that we'd have to have goggles on the
whole time and it's a whole thing okay
well I don't know what that means that
sounds that sounds like a cawthorne
sexual get-together dinner party thing
yeah I'm the cocaine well right right or
you know meth uh I I I don't take
Madison gothron as a as a cocaine user
more as a meth user so I mean who else
beats up a tree right well it looks kind
of messy to me all right everyone until
tomorrow noon Eastern 11 Central Surf's
Up [ __ ] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's newborn headass Beacon